[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this video in
this video we are going to discuss the
DevOps salary range in today's market
now let's have a look at the agenda for
today we are going to look at primarily
full-time jobs which require you to
either go to an office or maybe work
from home on some days of the week but
full-time jobs will be the focus of this
video we'll have a look at the salary
range based on a number of parameters
such as experience expertise and
location and we'll look at challenges
faced at various levels look at role
based salary and then what is the
toolset required in the current market
to be a successful DevOps engineer so
full-time jobs you normally look for
those on indeed or dice in the United
States and in India you would look on na
curry or monster so there's a normal
interview process for a full-time job
where you go to their office and you
have your resume and you justify your
resume in a face to face interview so
initially it might be a screening over
the phone and then perhaps a Skype video
screening and then they may call you in
to have a face-to-face interview with
their technical or HR teams depending on
the complexity of the process or the
organization and then finally you might
have a salary discussion where they want
to know the details of your current
salary and what your expectations are
now if you're coming from a non DevOps
background they might also want to
discuss what your expectation is coming
from a non DevOps background so your
salary expectation might be different
based on your background and then
finally you would receive an offer
letter and to be hired now let's have a
look at what you might expect in the
offer letter from a salary perspective
so there is a different salary range
depending on your level of experience
and that would be obviously different at
each level so say your refresher it's
gonna be different than if you had three
years experience and that's going to be
different than someone with say six
years experience or which would be
different than someone with ten years
experience or more so let's have a look
at the salaries for various levels of
experience as a fresher out of college
in the u.s. you're looking at fifty six
thousand dollars per annum and that's
including all benefits in India you get
three hundred thousand INR per annum and
that's including PF and any other
allowances the work you're expected to
do is entry-level work which would be
basic troubleshooting linux debugging
you could be on call support sometimes
you're kept on call under the shadow of
a senior resource most of the time in
the office you will be shadowing under a
senior resources and you would be
working under their mentorship they will
be guiding you on tasks which you need
to perform and they will be helping you
on issues which you are not able to
solve you will be enrolled in the basic
training on DevOps tools like chef
puppet ansible and the scripting
languages as well and you would also be
assigned it to fix minor production bugs
now as I said previously on call support
may be required frequently and you will
be asked to work as a shadow under
senior resources because you can't fix
issues in production single-handedly at
that stage now let's go to the next
level for someone with three years of
experience the salary for someone with
three years of experience in the u.s. is
$80,000 per annum in India it's the
eight hundred thousand INR per annum and
you will be required to have mid-level
technical experience and the work is
also mid-level technical and the issues
and tasks assigned are not really highly
technical you are required to take
initiative on your own and suggest
things although your suggestions might
not be the route that the company takes
major production issues are assigned to
you although you might be given some
help or mentorship or necessary you are
also required to participate in
corporate change and design meetings and
you might be involved with the
architects or design meetings where your
input might be taken so let's have a
look at someone with six years of
experience with regard to their salary
and work experience expectations now in
the US a salary is around $100,000 per
annum and in India the salary is around
fourteen hundred thousand INR per
expert level work is expected at this
level and no training is provided for
most of the work you'll be concentrating
on chef puppet and ansible and you
wouldn't be working to fix production
issues you'll be working to get it
things automated and solve day-to-day
issues of the dev team you will provide
remedies and suggest new technologies
you'll also be required to work on
scripting in Python or shell and you
will be required to automate application
deployments and set up continuous
delivery and continuous integration
pipelines you'll also be required to set
up monitoring and logging systems and
you'll be required to know Linux
debugging in depth so you should know
how Linux works and how to debug
production issues in Linux now for
someone who has more than ten years
experience the salary in the US would be
a hundred and thirty thousand per annum
and in India 20 hundred thousand INR per
annum these are just ballpark figures
for someone with this much experience
salary is really based on negotiation if
you have more certifications or if you
have if you know more tools like if
you're an expert in Python chef or Ruby
you can get up to 150 thousand in the US
and twenty five or thirty or even more
in India at this level architecture and
design level work is expected out of you
and you should suggest how to architect
stuff solution architecture is also
expected because a client may want to
implement a new solution and you would
be required to give your input there you
will be mentoring and leading teams of
six or seven people at this stage you'll
also be involved in client interactions
you are also required to be an expert in
at least one of the programming
languages and configuration management
tools I would say Python would be the
best choice because it's very popular
and it integrates with a lot of other
systems so at this stage you should have
a good number of certifications and you
should know at least a couple of
programming languages you should be
familiar with least one or two cloud
platforms and you should have an
architecture level understanding of
those things now let's have a look at
the DevOps tool set required for a
typical dev
engineer in the market these days so you
should know one of the cloud platforms
it could be Amazon Web Services Google
cloud platform or maybe Microsoft Azure
you should also know about configuration
management tools like chef puppet and
ansible these are the most popular in
the market right now and at least you
should know chef and ansible so for
application deployment you should know
one of the CIC V tools the most popular
ones on the market today are jenkins and
bamboo from a scripting perspective you
should know python ruby and shell well
python is the hot one on the market and
it has a high level language and gives
you very easy interface to automation
frameworks from a linux perspective you
should know at least a boon too because
that's the default OS for the cloud
right now from a containers perspective
you should know docker and kubernetes
that's good but docker is a prerequisite
every job description in the market
requires you to have a knowledge of
containers and finally once you deploy
systems you really need to monitor them
so you should have good knowledge on one
of the monitoring systems so Nagios is
one of the open source leaders uber uses
Nagios to monitor its systems Splunk is
from the interface side so it's it's
good to know either one of these the
simply learn advantages are there's a
comprehensive hands-on training program
which covers each topic in detail we
have support for lab issues so if you
have any issues in your local lab you
could raise a support ticket we have the
latest industry based content which
gives you good insight to what people
are actually using we have an amazing
collection of self-paced courses which
you can subscribe to we have related
technology courses so let's say you do a
DevOps course and you now want to do an
AWS course we have that at simply
learned we help you learn everything
from scratch there's no assumption that
you know anything so we do it all from
scratch we let you do all the setups
from scratch every setup of every tool
every programming language is taught
from scratch so that gives you an edge
in the industry and you'll nobody ends
in the outs of things and all the
courses that simply learn are designed
in such a way so that you can
understand them easily thanks for your
time and good luck in your career hey
once become an expert in cloud computing
then subscribe to simpler Channel and
click here to watch more such videos
turn it up and get certified in cloud
computing click here